hi my name is marsh i'm a product
manager
on the apigee team and joining me today
is evan from hp
we'll be talking about developer
engagement and how it supports digital
transformation
digital transformation is a less violent
way of saying
software is eating the world it means
adapting to business opportunities
presented by digitally enabled
experiences
and i've spent the last 10 years helping
apg customers adapt their existing
businesses to this new landscape
while there are tools that can help with
some of this transition
there's also a cultural shift that's
happening
digital transformation isn't just a
package install it's a change in how
people work
now real meaningful change takes time
but
it also can happen in bursts
for the last few months as the world's
faced a pandemic we've had to adapt
faster
how we live how we work it's
dramatically different than it was in
january
to say we've been disrupted would be an
understatement
and now today i'm much more likely to
see my family and friends through a
screen
than in person
adapting to shifts and new technologies
this has been going on for a long long
time
automation really got going in the 1800s
as the power loom transformed the
textile industry with programmable looms
such as the jacquard machine
which then made it easier to reproduce
patterns
this changed the way people do their
work if you fast forward to today
now many physical objects have digital
interfaces
i can ask the google assistant to turn
on my lights i've added a device to my
garage door
so that it opens when i pull into the
driveway
apis are how these things talk to each
other when i order groceries on my phone
apis fire off the different systems then
make that happen
teaching all these systems how to talk
to each other and i would enable these
digital experiences
that requires people developers and
today
evan and i will be talking about how
enabling developers
is a critical part of this digital
transformation journey
so creating this great developer
experience you build apis
these are products and you bring them to
market and keep in mind there are many
go-to-market strategies
you need to find the one that works for
you you might begin by
trying to improve your internal business
efficiency
or perhaps your best opportunity is to
launch apis that support a partner
program or
maybe the opportunities creating apis
for a large number of developers that
you've never met
each of these approaches is going to
affect how you think about what will
make
a great developer experience for each of
those channels
so first developers are your customers
whether they're for
internal or external or partner use
cases
they're the consumers of your apis
second you need a way to bring them to
market that's a storefront
just like any product in a marketplace
those apis need to be discovered
learned about and adopted third
we think of a developer portal as a
storefront for apis
this is where you are building a great
developer experience that
makes onboarding easy helps people get
through to their first api requests
and all the way along that journey to
when they have problems how do they get
support
productizing your apis that's one part
of it
but in addition to being valuable to
developers your apis have to be
discoverable
once a developer finds your apis they're
going to need great documentation
you're going to need support and other
resources to help them to succeed
can't just go out and buy digital
transformation it's part of how you
change your business
but there are tools that can help you on
your way just as important there are
hard-fought lessons you can learn from
companies who've been going through
these transformations
like hp they've been on this journey
five six or seven years at this point
and with that i'd like to turn it over
to evan who could
talk to you about how hp's is developer
experience to drive
their digital transformation strategy
evan great to have you
thank you marsh uh yeah i really
appreciate the opportunity to speak
at google's invitation and about this
topic that we both
share so much enthusiasm for myself evan
chesley i've worked at hp for about 20
years and
in my space is developer engagement and
api strategy
generally it's part of our company's
work in digital transformation in fact i
work in our office of digital
transformation and transformation
organization um today i'm going to talk
about what this journey
has been like for us and what's
important is that it's
not a done journey it's underway there's
a lot
we've been learning and that means that
there have been course corrections along
the way and that's an important aspect
that i really want to have come through
specifically though there's a few points
i just want to make sure that you are
attending to and that you take away by
the end of this this brief session
um like marsh said apis aren't projects
they're
products and there's a rich embodiment
of that that
we've really learned to embrace api
management's essential
absolutely but as an enabler of this
product life cycle
there's a marketplace in play here that
involves developers and it might not be
what you think
and developer experience is a thing
it's an important frame to
moving in a digital direction and
working with apis and developers and
creating that value that enterprises
seek to unlock
now this sounds like a interesting story
coming from hp you know we're a hardware
company right
back in the 30s we got started um bill
hewlett and dave packard
going to the origins of silicon valley
in fact the first garage if you've ever
heard of a startup in a garage
the first silicon valley garage were our
founders
starting a company and selling their
first product that gray box there to
disney to make fantasia
and constant adaptation and
adjustments to their their product
thinking along the way
what you see here you know we're known
for computers and printers now but on
the screen
you know these are oscilloscopes and
calculators and a wrist watch
um it's a company that really does
embrace our motto keep reinventing and
that's
been essential to our movement into
digital and
accelerating in this direction the last
10 or so years
what we are today you know a lot of a
lot of
business-minded people think about hp as
the pc maker and indeed we
sell more pcs than any other company on
earth uh
july 2020 just last month we uh we held
the number one position
and we obviously uh to most folks know
that we have a huge printing business
from tiny little handheld consumer
printers to
presses that fill factories to 3d
printing
that printing business is essentially
based on this idea of placing hardware
so that we can have a supplies revenue
stream
kind of like the the classic business
school
razors and blades model right you sell
the razer so that you can get that
annuity stream
of revenue from selling the blades or
often i think also the coffee maker and
the coffee pods
is very similar well with hp you know
we're known for
ink placing printers so that that ink
sales happens and uh what's great about
of course is we we believe we do make
um an important contribution to society
in this space because our content
is physical uh hp makes you know the
the online experience a little more real
when you can print a photo
and likewise we're moving in directions
and investing heavily beyond just
simple you know classic printing you
know we in some cases we sell
ink by the thousand liter tote and we
sell materials for 3d printings
in our nascent 3d printing business in
the industrial side
a lot of growth there in this again
physical content space
but in a business model point of view
it's still about placing
units and a lot of revenue and a lot of
you know business happening through the
use and consumption of supplies
now all this is great but this is a
software talk right
um what does any of this have to do with
software well it's where we're coming
from and it's it's
important foundation for our direction
that we're heading now
um you know hp has had software in mind
for decades
uh we've even you know we've packaged
software with our devices we've had to
write device drivers with
operating system partners um often
though software was
seen as an accessory to be you know
included in the box at the lowest
possible expense
just a necessity that wasn't central to
the value proposition of printers or pcs
and such
it's got to evolve from there where
we're
coming from is this old model right this
idea that there's a factory and on the
inside we invent things we make them and
we ship them out the door to the outside
world
you know marketing brings it to market
and we either have a direct or indirect
you know channel sales a classic
antiquated physical hardware
industrial model so we're learning to
add
software as a as a principle
to this model right let's add another
dimension and
keep that hardware side right we're
still a mechanical engineering
you know strong manufacturing company
um but if we think of software as its
own
piece to this equation you know now we
can think of the
in the factory or back office software
investments which are essential to a
multinational company like ours
but also there's the outside software
like going to market with software
having
digital businesses this cloud modern
2020 approach
to building and growing businesses based
on software
so now we have a way of thinking about
it now how do we make it real well
we start with our foundation we have
our hardware placed all around the world
from small to large
consumer commercial industrial how do we
grow these digital businesses you know
these software emotions on top of it
well it starts with extensibility right
how are we going to
bring new value through our hardware
well the hardware has to be software
extensible
and that means partnering right who's
going to use those
extensions who's going to participate
with us it's our business partners
well who among those business partners
well those are the developers really
right we have to be working with
developers
to create these new experiences to
address those markets
and ultimately what do those developers
need what do they consume
it's our friend the api so this has been
one of our
years past epiphanies right really
getting our heads wrapped around apis
aren't just
integration necessities like a new
supplier needs to be able to submit an
invoice and so they have to call an api
to you know get
paid or something no it it's about
growing ecosystems and creating new
value in the business motion
so really we've recently gotten our
hands around the
the fundamental value proposition of
apis and so
we're gonna really you know work with
that in fact we we
started to adopt a mindset of build
those apis place those apis and they'll
create
value like that classic ink revenue
stream
of you know placing printers and seeing
their usage
create revenue through supplies
consumption
so yeah maybe you know the api is the
new ink
well let's manage that if it's going to
be that fundamental
and that critical then we're going to
learn about apis and
ensure we have structure to manage and
control and
and really run them so api management
right this is how we came
to start working with apogee and apogee
google
in our work is this you know this
imperative to ensure that we have uh a
firm grasp on our api strategy
you know management is essential right
these assets are too important
and so we did our research we we really
came to find that the apogee's
enterprise
savvy data model and structure for
federation and security
authentication a lot of great features
that map to our kind of enterprise scale
complexity
really important work to get our arms
all
wrapped around the api management
space and again just kind of classic
back office muscle that we had like we
need a new erp
we know how to bring that in and bring
it up to speed to serve our business
api management same kind of motion uh
research
adopt build out that capability
and you know the the outside world tells
us this is an
appropriate motion um here's gartner's
view of
enterprise or digital business landscape
platform thinking
like a robust api management suite is a
software platform not just a tool you
you wire in
and where does it fit on a full
enterprise
view of this uh this landscape well it's
in that partnering
facet where api management and the
developer portal components go whether
it's customer facing or it's internal or
partner facing right like that
that's the side of this landscape that
we're operating and it was
um reassuring to see that you know
enterprise business
strategists and and deep thinkers are
putting this work
as a major facet of our our go forward
investments
so for us you know that meant a lot of
investment in understanding the data
model and
the controls the knobs how do we
structure our thinking around api
management
obviously apogee is a product foundation
but it's got this
organizational or data model structure
that
for you know a non-trivial enterprise
you have to wield that
appropriately and make it fit into your
organizational landscape
and then deeper in the data model
there's all these other elements that
serve an important purpose and allow us
to hone
toward getting the most value out of the
management platform the most visibility
and observability and
security um you know these are
essential pieces but then what we've
learned
as we've been doing this for the last
five years now
we learned that this wasn't necessarily
the goal
right you know rolling this out and in
in making those in those integrations
work
rolling out making the integrations work
and ensuring the controls are in place
was necessary but wasn't
our final objective oh something's
missing there
and our developers our own internal
developers kind of helped remind us of
this
and that is this idea that i mentioned
that really there's a product management
story and uh if there's a product that
means there's a customer and if there's
a customer there's a customer experience
so
you know your nba types are gonna you
know light bulbs are going off and
saying that's right customer experience
matters no matter what
back office it process or hr process or
anything there's always
a relationship and there's an experience
and so we've
recently pivoted to started really
internalized the thinking that api
management is a foundation
on which we build a product value
proposition
and that the api is the product not just
a managed element of our
our model of our our operations and
integrations
so we've moved api management now as
this foundational enabler it's like this
you know well-built road on which
commerce can run
on that now we can build software
development standards and
process automation pipelines that'll
ensure consistent
software projects and services and then
on that
is the real work of product management
the full life cycle from
birth to getting it out in front of
customers
to iterating to even sunsetting products
um this is our new frame um the api
isn't the
tip of that pyramid really it's the
product
that has those relationships rolled up
in it
so it's about relationships it's about
relationships with developers
and that means that this
original work of understanding the data
model it remains
in place but we've learned to start
shifting our focus to another dimension
right like let's going
up in the business model stack into
seeing those relationships and measuring
the engagement with the product like
we're we're now up into even net
promoter score
space we're thinking about the product
and the value it's creating
this is a graph that is fundamentally a
different
view on the work this is about the
relationships between different kinds of
developers
and the apis and the product embodiment
of those apis but also the runtime
you know real-time nature of apis and
we've even learned to embrace that
developers come in different types
there's the developers who make your
apis and the developers who consume
those apis and
they have different kinds of
relationships and different stages of
life cycles
reliability and security remain
essential right the run time remains
essential but our focus is now
or maybe our site line has shifted to
better
see how the value is really created by
this work
now some of you might say isn't this
developer relations we're talking
marketing now and
no we're really thinking still about the
platform
but in a sense yes we're enriching our
platform thinking with
a concept of relationships and
developers experience
with the product as a first order
concern there is a classic value chain
view
that might be familiar to some of you
this um is a reflection of
apogee's original digital value chain
where we've got users who consume
apps built by developers who consume the
api
that is offered by these publishers and
what we're
doing now and how we're investing our
energy looking at this space
from 2020 going forward is we're really
looking at
a couple of different developer journeys
there's the consumer developer journey
and there's this
publisher side the creator side there
are developer experiences
each but they're also different and
you know this is is a different step
or a different element entirely of
working with apis than thinking about
just
publish apis and the value is inherent
right we're no longer just
in you know thinking about shipping apis
like we'd ship a printer hardware
and there would be uh
value inherent in that all right we're
thinking about the
actions of these consumers of these
publishers as being
the the measured value is happening
there
in fact there's there's a gap in this
diagram that
is the missing piece and it's where they
find each other
and where's the classic business school
concept of where
suppliers and consumers find each other
it's a marketplace
i use the word marketplace very
generally we're always thinking in terms
of
a developer portal more or less but it's
a marketplace of ideas
is what i've learned to adopt as a
philosophy for
why the portal serves the features it
has
and how you measure its success
it isn't just uptime it isn't just
performance of you know page views and
such it's
our consumers finding what they're
looking for and
um unlocking value from a catalog
of assets published by our developer
community
if hp is going to offer apis we need to
offer apis that
are products which unlock value and they
only matter even the best api product
doesn't matter unless
it's consumed by somebody who is
you know having that value right
is experiencing it and solving their
problems so
really this this puts in perspective
this portal work right
why does this portal fit into this
equation it's because it's where these
two communities can
meet each other in a credible like
believable it will be
that marketplace where my participating
community finds what we're doing also
beyond
the portal is just a place for discovery
we're also learning that
it unlocks insight through
instrumentation
analytics happens throughout the digital
value chain
but at the portal where products are
being published and iterated and
our internal and external partners are
finding them
evaluating them and choosing and
engaging with our apis
there's rich analytics that come out of
that that better inform
how well this platform is working and
what you know further
investments are needed so
looking forward you know simplifying our
our energy here we're putting energy
into that discovery and engagement part
the portal
not just as again a a web platform but
as a place for both the consumers and
the publishers to efficiently
and confidently perform their work
right either searching for finding and
getting on with life using some api or
sdk
but also the publishers who need to know
that this is how the catalog works this
is the ultimate catalog where i want my
work to be discovered on and as
efficiently and as consistent and
securely as possible
on the other side we think about the
developers in community
we have to invest in their resources for
q a
and consistent standards and
topic tagging between things so that
search works uh
good solid answers are always available
when needed on how to run
uh and and be a successful developer in
our company
and connecting it the interstitial
fabric
is analytics it's understanding um
really what connects all these
experiences we can instrument a lot of
our
digital tool change or developers you
know code pipelines and api runtimes
and even web analytics on the portal
together
creating a really rich graph that better
illuminates how well
we are addressing our customers and our
our developer partners needs
so the takeaway is it's a journey and
it's not about any one end goal but it
is about being willing to
reinvent how you think about your
partners think about
opening interfaces think about apis as
products
um there's a whole life cycle in apis
that
recently has come to light for us on how
to invest in it as
you know from end to end and api
management absolutely essential
apigee has been a powerful enabler for
us to
to meet our needs for management but now
we're
also seeing how it further extends that
value into the product life cycle
developers need a marketplace for their
ideas whether you're looking for
something or you're looking to
ensure your work is discoverable
and the best way to understand those
developers
needs and requirements and expectations
is what we call developer experience
it supports all of those different
developer journeys and it's the right
kind of product frame of mind for
thinking about
unlocking your your enterprise's
ultimate value as you move from
hardware or whatever legacy business
structure to really
services that build on top of your
foundations
and help you move forward and compete
and with that uh thank you very much
again march for the invite
and if you have any questions you can
reach out to me evan
hp.com thanks evan it was really
fascinating to hear you talk through the
journey
hp has been on and put into context of
the different transformations that hp's
faced through the years like the shift
to delivery and it was really great to
hear
how you've walked through that and given
the lesson sauce that we can learn from
thank you very much
very welcome thank you